[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend für den Sport im Studio ist
wieder Katja streso ja und heute geht
die handballem los schönen guten Abend
verschaffen wir uns jetzt einen
Überblick dre Tage Bahnstreik die
loogführer legen erneut ihre Arbeit
nieder reisende müssen sich auf massive
zugausf
einstellen brisantes treffen
afdptiker Neonazis und rechte
Unternehmer sollen die Vertreibung von
Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland
besprochen
haben und bereit für ein Wintermärchen
die deutsche Handballnationalmannschaft
startet am Abend vor mehr als 50.000
Zuschauern in die
heimem es ist eine ziemlich harte Woche
für Pendler Schüler und Reisende die
Landwirte protestieren und blockieren
vielfach den Verkehr aber auch die
Lockführer sind wieder im Streik bis
Freitag fallen rund 80% der
Fernverbindungen aus große Probleme gibt
es auch im Regionalverkehr im ZDF
verteidigt gdlchef selski den Streik und
droht sogar damit ihn auszuweiten Andrea
Mäuser seit heute Nacht um 2 wird der
Personenverkehr der Deutschen Bahn
bestreikt aber nicht überall bietet sich
das gleiche Bild in manchen Städten wie
hier in München gibt es viele
Zugausfälle in Frankfurt konnte sich
mancher mit ein bisschen Planung
durchwursteln also die S-Bahn ist
Gefahren man muss s natürlich vorm
Internet schlau machen und in Hamburg
hörte man auch Berichte von entspannten
Fahrten in pünktlichen Zügen alles super
Zug war leer ich hat den Sitzplatz mit
ihrem Notfahrplan kann die Bahn nach
eigenen Angaben 20% des Bahnverkehrs
aufrechterhalten entscheidend ist dabei
der Organisationsgrad der GDL und
natürlich die Zahl privater nicht
bestreigter bahnanbieter begleitet wird
der Arbeitskampf von einem Kampf der
Woch die Bahn muss Angebote machen und
die Menschen hier in diesem Land nie
weiter täuschen und ihnen was vorgaugeln
die muss Angebote machen die
substantiell sind wir sind bereit
Kompromisse zu bilden und die
Wochenarbeitszeit schrittweise
abzusenken s dass die Arbeitgeberseite
Gelegenheit hat auch auszubilden wir
haben ein flexible Modelle in der
Arbeitszeit vorgeschlagen es ist jetzt
an der Zeit darüber zu verhandeln und
ins Gespräch zu kommen Gespräch und
Verhandlung das wünschen sich auch die
Bahnkunden egal ob Sie Kritik oder
Verständnis äußern ich erlebe den Streik
als sehr unangenehm zumal ich die
Forderungen der Gewerkschaft als total
überzogen empfinde wenn die streiken
wollen dann haben sie ein Recht dazu und
dann unterstütze ich 100% mach weniger
fürs gleiche Geld wenn das jeder so
machen würde ne in jedem Beruf ich weiß
nicht wie das dann enden würde der
Streik soll bis Freitag 18 Uhr dauern
gibt es bis dahin kein neues Angebot
will die GDL eine kurze Pause machen und
dann ihren Arbeitskampf fortsetzen
in den letzten Jahren gab es immer
wieder gdlstreiks für mehr Geld in
unserer ZDF heute App haben wir
zusammengestellt wie sich die Gehälter
der Lockführer entwickelt haben und wie
viel sie im Vergleich zu anderen Berufen
verdienen wie erwähnt legen auch die
Bauern den Verkehr lahm mit
treckeraktionen machen sie Druck auf die
Regierung es gibt Proteste im ganzen
Land Schwerpunkte heute Dresden Augsburg
und Bremerhafen wo laut
Hafengesellschaft die Container
Terminals blockiert wurden das könnte
sich alles noch verschärfen sollte die
Ampel die Subventionskürzungen nicht
zurücknehmen das droht der Bauernverband
und das bekam auch
Landwirtschaftsminister östemir im
badenwürtembergischen elwangen zu spüren
Luisa
Huben sie sind nach elwangen gekommen
voller Wut auf die Ampel in
Berlin und treffen hier auf den
Landwirtschaftsminister
selbst
mein Eindruck ist es geht gar nicht nur
um den Agrardiesel das ist eigentlich
Metapher für viele der ungelösten
Probleme die Kundgebung mitorganisiert
hat Landwirt Hubert Kucher er hat 250
Tiere bewirtschaftet 90 Hektar Land
fällt die Subvention für den Agrardiesel
Weg wie von der Ampel geplant fehlen ihm
im Jahr mehr als 5000 € sagt er brauchen
das Geld auch um unsere Rechnung zu
bezahlen um unsere Familie zu erähen um
der Betrieb laufe zu halte für ihn geht
es darum ob sein Sohn einmal übernimmt
dafür brauche es faere Bezahlung und
weniger Bürokratie um wettbewerbsfähig
zu sein neuen Anforderungen an
Tierhaltung und Klimaschutz gerecht zu
werden im Saal sagt der Minister seine
Unterstützung zu aber übersehen sie mal
nicht der Agrarminister hat kein wetcht
auch wenn ich mir manchmal heimlich
wünschen würde so ich bin halt auch Teil
des Kabinetts ich habe Landesminister
ich habe Europa und muss halt in dem
Rahmen machen was ich kann konkrete neue
Maßnahmen stellt er nicht vor es wäre
auch ganz gut gewesen wenn er dann
vielleicht noch mehr ins Detail gegangen
wäre um die Zukunft Landwirtschaft zu
beschreiben wie die junge landwtinnen
und landwte ihre Zukunft gestalten
könntet und so gehen die Proteste weiter
laut Bauernverband wenn nötig auch über
nächsten Montag
hinaus dass der Verfassungsschutz die
AFD als rechtsextremen Verdachtsfall
führt hält die Partei für falsch und
politisch
aber offenbar hat sie keine
Berührungsängste einflussreiche AFD
Politiker trafen sich vor se Wochen mit
prominenten rechtsextrem so berichtet es
das Medienhaus Korrektiv Thema des
brisanten Treffens wie man Millionen
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund auch
jene mit deutschem Pass aus Deutschland
vertreiben kann Thomas Reichert und
Ulrich
Stoll das Geheimtreffen findet Ende
November in diesem Gästehaus in Potzdam
statt anwesend auch hochrangige AFD
Mitglieder wie Ulrich Siegmund
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD in Sachsen
Anhalt das zeigen Recherchen von
Korrektiv die bei dem Treffen verdeckt
drehen konnten an dem Abend ging es um
die Idee Millionen Menschen abzuschieben
auch solche mit deutschem Pass die
einleidung verspricht einen Zitat
Masterplan zur sogenannten Remigration
kein geringerer als Martin selner werde
das Vorstellen höchst
vertraulich das ist selner bei dem
Treffen Leitfigur der rechtsextremen
identitären Bewegung deners Plan sieht
vor auch politisch missliebige Menschen
nach Afrika abzuschieben hier zeigt sich
dass selbst hochrangige AFD Politiker
Position radikal rechtsradikale Position
vertreten haben in einem abgeschlossenen
Raum die sie nach außen hin nie
wiedergeben würden und das zeigt
natürlich die Radikalität im Inneren
dieser Partei bei dem Treffen ist auch
der frühere AFD Fraktionsgeschäftsführer
Roland Hartwig angeblich wusste er nicht
dass Seer auftritt hatwig ist ein enger
Vertrauter von Bundessprecherin Alis
Weidel sie äußert sich heute nur
schriftlich die AFD wird ihre halung zur
Einwanderungspolitik die im
Parteiprogramm nachzulesen ist und die
vollständig im Einklang mit dem
Grundgesetz steht nicht abändern doch im
Netz greift die AFD genau diese Rhetorik
auf das zeigt eindeutig dass die AFD
entgegen aller Beteuerungen sich viel
weiter im Rechtsextremismus
radikalisiert und wir dürfen auch nichts
ausschließen bishin zu einem möglichen
Verbotsverfahren so könnte das heimliche
Treffen brisant werden für ein mögliches
Verbot der
AFD nach einem mehrjährigen exportstoppp
hat die Bundesregierung wieder eine
rüstungslieferung nach Saudi-Arabien
genehmigt dabei handelt es sich um 150
Lenkflugkörper des Typs Iris t die
Bundesregierung begründete die neue
Haltung damit dass Saudi-Arabien eine
sehr konstruktive Haltung gegenüber
Israel einnehme die saudi-arabische
Luftwaffe hatte zuletzt zahlreiche
Raketen der hui Rebellen abgeschossen
die auf dem Weg nach Israel
waren auf Waffenlieferungen drängt auch
die Ukraine Präsident selenski erneuerte
bei seinem Besuch im natoland Litauen
seine wichtigste Botschaft vor allem an
Deutschland kievs Militär brauche mehr
Luftabwehrsysteme allein über den
Jahreswechsel habe Russland mit mehr als
500 Raketen und Drohnen angegriffen und
die Attacken dauern an aus der Ukraine
berichtet Alisa jung
diese Hochschule in hakiv wurde von
einer Rakete getroffen mitten durchs
Dach seit Tagen feuert Russland auf
ukrainische
Städte leider ist es nicht das erste Mal
das Gebäude wurde schon dreimal
getroffen an diesem Ort werden Schüler
in mechanischem Ingenieurwesen
unterrichtet Russland behauptet
militärische Ziele anzugreifen trifft
aber Zivilisten die ukrainische
Luftverteidigung ist
Dauereinsatz wenn der Feind mit einer
großen Anzahl von Raketen und Drohnen
angreift ist es sicherlich sein Ziel
unser Luftverteidigungssystem zu
überfordern erklärt uns der Sprecher der
Luftstreitkräfte die Ukraina habe nicht
genügend Mittel um die hohe Zahl
ballistischer Raketen abzuwehren die
Russland in den letzten Tagen auf zivile
Ziele geschossen hat
sagt die Ukraine hat das Recht sich zu
verteidigen nicht nur das Recht sondern
die Pflicht das mit Waffen zu
dazu gehört für die Ukraine nicht nur
die direkte Luftverteidigung sondern
auch die Möglichkeit Logistik
Lagerhäuser und Kommandoposten Russlands
zu zerstören dabei helfen würde auch der
Taurus Marschflugkörper aus Deutschland
die taurusrakete verfügt über taktische
und technische Eigenschaften mit
größerer Reichweite die es uns
ermöglichen wird Ziele in größerer Tiefe
der feindlichen Verteidigung zu
erreichen niemand will sich hier
vorstellen stte iche Unterstützung
aussähen jetzt zu Ulf Röller nach
Brüssel wo die Ukraine heute auch im
Fokus stand Ulf vor allem beim Thema
Waffen und
munitionslieferung wie viel Hoffnung
kann sich Kiev da
machen also die NATO die ja heute den
Nato ukraineerat hatte der hier getagt
hat wollte natürlich ein bisschen
Hoffnung verbreiten aber eigentlich war
das ein Krisentreffen die Ukrainer haben
gebeten dass es zu diesem Krisentreffen
kommt der Luftwaffenchef Ukraine hat
noch mal sehr sehr deutlich gemacht wie
dramatisch die Lage ist das hat er bei
der Sitzung deutlich erklärt er hat
gesagt dass man zwar immer noch hohe
abfangquoten hat von russischen
geschossen aber dass ein langsam die
Munition ausgehen auch der Bundeskanzler
hat im Vorfeld gesagt dass mehr
geliefert werden muss von Europa aber
eben mit den Zusagen Harpers auch hier
bei dem natorat hat das nicht ganz
deutlich geklappt italien will ein
bisschen mehr geben England will ein
bisschen mehr geben aber insgesamt hat
man den Eindruck dass die
Waffenlieferung doch sehr schleppend und
zögerlich laufen und dann gibt es noch
ein ganz großes Problem für die Ukraine
dass eigentlich der wichtigste Partner
zur Zeit nämlich Amerika ausfällt dort
gibt es einen großen innenpolitischen
Streit um die ukrainehilfe und damit ist
um Amerika blockiert
Ulf vielen Dank nach Brüssel ja wie ist
die Situation an der Front in der
Ukraine auch heute live schaut hin zu
seehen um 19:30 Uhr auf der z App bzw
auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen der russische Oppositionsführer
navalni hat sich erstmals per Video aus
dem Straflager in der Polarregion
gemeldet Alexei navalni gilt ja als
größter innenpolitischer Gegner von
Präsident Putin nach einem Giftanschlag
2020 kam er in die Berliner Charité als
er nach Moskau zurückkehrte wurde er
verhaftet und wegen Extremismus zu 19
Jahren Haft verurteilt die verbüste
jetzt 2000 km entfernt von Moskau in der
Strafkolonie Polarwolf am Rande des
Uralgebirges ein Bericht von Armin
Körper seine Unterstützer Filmen mit dem
Handy wie er per Video aus der
Strafkolonie zugeschaltet wird Alexi
navalni kämpft für sein Recht und bleibt
doch für alle sichtbar hinter Gittern
Russlands Staatsfeind Nummer 1 nur in
sozialen Netzwerken kann das Team
navalni zeigen wie er mit Journalisten
im gerichtssal scherzt mir geht es gut
das einzige Problem vor welchem Gericht
kann ich eigentlich gegen das schlechte
Wetter klagen denn navalne sitzt in
einer der kältesten Gegenden Russlands
ein mit diesem Foto zeigt er gestern
seinen sogenannten Hofgang bei
-32° insgesamt hat er ein Dutzend
Gerichtsverfahren gegen seine
Haftbedingungen angestrengt das ganze
mutet an wie ein bizarres Spiel navalni
klagt weil er die Aufmerksamkeit will
das russische Regime weiß das zu
verhindern indem die stat kontrollierten
Medien über ihn gar nicht berichten
trotzdem spielt der Kremmel das Spiel
mit um sich den Anschein von
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu geben und
navalnis Unterstützer spielen Katz und m
mit dem Kremmel zwei Monate vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl Plakatieren qrcod
die zur Wahl gegen Vladimir Putin
aufrufen solche Kampagnen die die
Rechtmäßigkeit der Wahl angreifen
beunrüend den Kremmel deshalb ist es für
die Machthaber notwendig navalni von
seinen Unterstützern Anwälten der ganzen
Welt zu isolieren und sperren ihn Weg
ans kalte Ende des russischen
Riesenreichs Alexi navalne hat seinen
Auftritt heute sichtlich genossen es ist
ein kleiner Triumph für einen der seine
Freiheit für sehr lange Zeit verloren
hat jetzt nach Polen wo sich nach vier
Wochen nach vier Wochen nach der
Parlamentswahl unglaubliche Szenen
abspielen im Palast des
Staatspräsidenten werden der Ex-Minister
und sein Staats Sekretär verhaftet beide
wegen Amtsmissbrauchs verurteilt
hintergrund ist der Konflikt zwischen
der neuen mitteelinksregierung und der
abgewählten Nationalkonservativen
peacepartei über den sich zuspitzenden
Konflikt berichtet Natalie Steger aus
Warschau Showdown im Präsidentenpalast
ausgerechnet dort werden gestern Abend
zwei rechtskräftig verurteilte
peacepitiker verhaftet es ist eine
Aktion die Polens nationalkonservative
offenbar provoziert haben Präsident duda
pisna hatte exinnenminister Kaminski und
dessen exstaatssekretär in den Palast
geholt er hatte sie persönlich nach
einer ersten Verurteilung 2015 begnadigt
für ihn gilt das heute noch ich bin von
dieser Situation tief erschüttert dass
sie inhaftiert wurden trotz der
präsidenziellen Begnadigung und dass man
es mit so viel Eifer und Brutalität
getan
hat wurden letzten Dezember in einem
Berufungsverfahren wegen früheren
Amtsmissbrauchs zu zwei Jahren Haft
verurteilt sie hatten einen politischen
Rivalen in inszenierte
Korruptionsverfahren verwickelt doch
peace parteichf katinski versucht die
Verhaftung als Racheaktion der neuen
Regierung zu verkaufen er und ein paar
ihm treue ziehen in der Nacht
demonstrativ zur Polizeistation
zwischenzeitlicher Zufluchtsort
Präsidentenpalast für verurteilte
Politiker Ministerpräsident Donald Tusk
und seine mitteelinksregierung
empört es ist der Versuch einer
Doppelherrschaft mit einem Engagement
der höchsten staatlichen Institution das
ist eine offensichtliche
Sabotage die peace will eine Staatskrise
inszenieren der Präsident ist die letzte
Hoffnung der
Nationalkonservativen der Fall jetzt ist
auch ein Vorgeschmack darauf dass die
peace alles versuchen wird um die neue
liberale Regierung Polens zu
torpedieren
das südamerikanische Ecuador versinkt in
Gewalt Drogenbanden bekämpfen sich
gegenseitig und fordern den Staat heraus
jetzt mit einer beispiellosen
Machtdemonstration vor laufender Kamera
drangen bewaffnete in einen staatlichen
Fernsehsender ein feuerten Schüsse ab
und nahmen Geiseln Spezialeinheiten
mussten anrücken um den Sender wieder
unter Kontrolle zu bringen bei mehreren
anderen Angriffen sollen mindestens acht
Menschen ums Leben gekommen sein die
Regierung verhängte den ausnahmezust
wir machen sportlich weiter mit Katja
streso Handball EM im eigenen Land ein
aufregender Abend für die Jungs heute
geht sie los die Handball EM das erste
Spiel für die deutschen es geht gegen
die Schweiz vor stimmungsvoller
Rekordkulisse 53 000 Fans werden in
Düsseldorf erwartet und schon in der
Halle steht Jork Polus Jork füllt es
sich denn bei dir schon so
langsam ja Katja absolut also die
meisten Zuschauer Zuschauer sind
wirklich schon sehr früh hingekommen und
die Halle die Arena hier in Düsseldorf
ist wirklich schon sehr gut gefüllt das
liegt zum einen daran dass der
sechsfache Weltmeister Frankreich gerade
schon spielt gegen nordmazedonien zum
anderen sind viele da doch schon sehr
früh hier angereist weil man einfach das
Verkehrschaos auf Grund des Bahnstreiks
gefürchtet hat das wichtigste allerdings
die deutsche Mannschaft die ist auch
schon an der Arena angekommen Juri Knorr
sehen wir da gerade den Spielmacher und
Alfred gisslerson der Bundestrainer
verlässt den Bus als einer der letzten
sie sollen also die Begeisterung hier
für die EM entfachen dazu muss aber ein
Sieg heute gegen die Schweizer und eine
leichte Aufgabe ist das heute ganz
bestimmt nicht ja anf ist 20:45 Uhr aber
ihr meldet euch gleich live hier nach
den heute Nachrichten morgen dann aber
auch wieder Biathlon im ZDF die deutsche
Männerstaffel ist dran und die dürfte
angespornt sein denn die Frauenstaffel
ist heute beim Heimweltcup in rupholding
als dritte aufs Podest gelaufen mit der
dritten Läuferin mit Franziska Preu
startet die auffuljagd Deutschland zum
ersten Mal auf dem Podest Preu übergibt
als erste auf Schlussläuferin Hanna
kebinger die verliert beim letzten
Schießen Zeit muss einmal Nachladen
dennoch nach dem enttäuschenden fünften
Platz von Oberhof heute Rang 3 klar wir
waren jetzt bisschen in der
Drucksituation dass wir Podium machen
beim heimwelt Cup und von dem her war
jeder angespannt die Französinnen
gewinnen souverän dahinter Schweden
Deutschland zum zweiten Mal in diesem
Winter unter den drei besten
in Kaunas Litau findet die Eiskunstlauf
em statt und die Chancen auf eine
Medaille für Deutschland die stehen gut
denn die Berlinerin Minerva Hase liegt
mit ihrem russischen partnerer Partner
Nikita volodin der für Deutschland
stberechtigt ist nach dem Kurzprogramm
auf Rang 2 die Entscheidung ist dann
morgen Abend in der
Kü ja und nach dem Tod von Franz
Beckenbauer liegt seit heute in der
Hofkapelle der Residenz München ein
Kondolenzbuch aus in das sich am
Vormittag auch er der des FC Bayern
eintrugen wie li höhnes oder auch
Karlheinz rumenige und am 19 Januar
gibt's dann in der Münchner Arena eine
große Gedenkfeier für den am vergangenen
Sonntag Verstorbenen Franz Beckenbauer
das war vom Sport vielen Dank Katja wir
blicken schnell auf die Zahlen vom
Mittwochslotto und die lauten 3 7 21 24
37 49 und Superzahl 9 alles noch mal zum
Nachlesen auf lotto. ztf.de und auf der
ztf Textseite
557 ja die Wintersonne weicht langsam
dem Hochnebel mehr Wetter gleich mit
Katja horneffer das heute journal das
gibt's dann in der Handballpause das ist
so gegen 21:20 Uhr mit Marietta Slomka
morgen über demimmt hierer Jana pareiges
vielen Dank schönen Abend und auf
[Musik]
bald
guten Abend heute gab es verschiedene
wetterzonen in Deutschland zum einen
hier diesen Hochnebel der von der Ostsee
weiterhin Richtung Schleswig-Holstein
zog dann aber viel Sonne in der Mitte
Deutschlands und ein paar dichtere
Wolkenfelder auch im Süden die sich zum
Teil aber auflösten und wenn es so klar
ist dann wird es nachts auch kalt dann
sinken die Temperaturen hier in
Thüringen bis -12° etwas weniger grimmig
ist der Frost an der Küste bei -1 bis
-3° und dazu ist es meistens klar nur im
Norden da gibt's diese hochnebeldecke
und zum Teil bildet sich auch mal
Bodennebel wenn der an dem gefrorenen
Boden festfriert dann wird's natürlich
glatt die hochnebeldecke zieht morgen im
Laufe des Tages weiter nach Süden
erreicht dann den Nordrand der
Mittelgebirge sonnig ist es dagegen von
der Mosel bis zur Donau und morgen
liegen dann die Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen -4° üb Schnee an den Alpen oder
auch in der Lausitz und + 4° an der
Küste und dann wird es von Tag zu Tag
ein bisschen milder am Sonntag erwarten
wir dann Höchsttemperaturen zwischen -1
und + 6°. am Freitag kann es in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen etwas Schnee
geben und dann wird es von Norden Regen
und Schnee geben und es drohen auch
wieder glatte Straßen guten Abend